do you have a chunk of code you really
need to show or a chunk of
text CTO is my favorite tool for
technical Communications here's a quick
CTO tip for making great presentation
slides maybe you need to emphasize a bit
of that code or text for a class or for
a presentation quoto slides give you a
bunch of options that help you emphasize
different parts of a slide you have code
chunk animation that lets you reveal new
bits of code within your chunk you can
highlight a bit of code or text with a
little bit of styling like color there's
also a bunch of slide fragment options
including highlighting with color easing
in easing out and more this might all
seem like a small trivial set of
features but these kind of highlighting
options make for good presentation and
good teaching practice there are so many
distractions in the classroom or in the
meeting room or in the zoom room help
your audience know where to look
highlight or emphasize exactly where you
are and what you're talking about this
helps make a more engaging bit of
technical communication follow for more
free and open- Source data science tips